et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Stéphane Le folle et ben oui bonjour
bonne année à tout le monde et bonne
année à vous également merci Alice
jument président de Le Mans Métropole on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Julien Lecuyer
de la Voix du Nord bonjour
de la réforme des retraites pour
évidemment parler du Parti socialiste
mais d'abord un mot puisque je sais que
vous vous suivez le foot Stéphane Le
fold sur Noël le grec qui a donc été mis
en retrait hier de la présidente de la
Fédération française de football après
de multiples polémiques des déclarations
mais aussi des témoignages sur des actes
présumés de sexistes est-ce que pour
vous cette mise en retrait est
suffisante en tout cas c'est une
décision des instances de la fédération
qui était absolument à mon avis
nécessaire le vrai sujet c'est qu'on
arrive à la fin d'un règne de Noël le
grec qui a commencé il y a 12 ans avec
d'ailleurs pour l'équipe de France des
résultats pas non plus oublier tout ça
mais maintenant il y a un moment où il
faut savoir aussi considérer que ce
règne avec l'exercice du pouvoir tel
qu'il a été
pratiqué par Noël levrette il faut que
ça s'arrête on peut pas avoir les
dérapages réguliers qui sont ceux que on
a entendu il y a vraiment aussi alors
après je ne sais pas dans le
fonctionnement de la Fédération des
choses qu'il faut revoir donc je pense
qu'on arrive à un moment où les
instances de la Fédération si Noël le
Grey ne décide pas lui-même de
considérer que il y a un moment où il
faut aussi savoir passer la main et bien
elle doit aussi prendre leur
responsabilités finalement la polémique
elle surgit avec les propos sur Zinédine
Zidane alors que sur la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar finalement ça n'avait pas
vraiment porté préjudice vous savez le
football a à la fois ce défaut et cette
capacité à faire que l'intérêt du sport
en tant tel enjeu a pris pas sur tout le
reste soyons honnêtes c'est ce qui s'est
passé et c'était à tout à fait
anticipable parce que le foot et
l'équipe de France en plus ce match
cette finale on va pas y revenir perdu
mais tu voyais bien bon reste des
problèmes de fond sur l'organisation de
ces grands événements sportifs à
l'échelle mondiale ça vaut pour le foot
mais ça vaut aussi pour les Jeux
Olympiques il y a des questions de fonds
qui se posent aujourd'hui dans ce que
l'on peut
considérer comme quelles sont les règles
et les critères qu'on va mettre
aujourd'hui pour accepter des grands
événements qui sont aussi des événements
de communion des événements très
importants de dépassement le sport c'est
aussi une manière de regarder les choses
autrement que simplement dans des
relations qui peuvent être
conflictuelles donc c'est important
faut-il savoir à partir de là comment
dois gérer tout ça et aujourd'hui toutes
ces fédérations et en particulier FFF
ont une manière de gérer tout ça en
disant c'est d'abord des choix en partie
financiers il y a le sport derrière qui
tire parce que c'est un tel engouement
que de toute façon quel que soit
l'édition comprend ça finit par passer
il y a un moment faut dire stop et je
pense que on est arrivé à ce moment
parler de la réforme des retraites
Julien oui moi je vais commencer
d'ailleurs par une question toute simple
il y a un mouvement il y a une journée
d'action qui est prévue le 19 janvier
est-ce que vous serez présent dans la
manifestation pour hurler contre la
réforme des retraites alors d'abord
poser comme ça et d'ailleurs c'est très
juste c'est hurler contre la réforme des
retraites d'abord quelle est ma position
voilà parce que c'est pas la
justification politique c'est pas
simplement est-ce que je vais dans la
rue soutenir le mouvement des syndicats
qui pour une fois et donc c'est un point
très important se retrouve tous d'accord
et en France jusqu'ici il y a pas encore
très longtemps c'est plutôt la désunions
ou la discorde quel est le problème de
la retraite donc ma position c'est que
je pense de manière très claire qui
n'avait pas besoin de cette réforme
telle qu'elle est présentée avec un
report de l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans
et 63 dès 2027 donc extrêmement rapide
c'est une réforme pour reprendre des
termes utilisés par certains
syndicalistes et spécialistes
paramétriques c'est simplement une
réforme budgétaire comment j'arrive à
récupérer 10 stress milliards d'euros le
plus rapidement possible alors
qu'aujourd'hui le système est sédentaire
et deuxième point il y a des choses on
sait très forte en même temps que l'âge
de de report de l'âge de de départ à la
retraite est annoncée des choses sur
lesquelles il manque vraiment là pour le
coup des décisions la question du
travail des seniors est une vraie
question
est-ce que les traités réellement ont
dit il va y avoir un index
qui a derrière qu'est-ce qui fait qu'ils
entreprises alors on dit le fait de
repousser l'âge légal va faire que les
entreprises vont garder et faire
travailler les seniors un peu plus voilà
c'est des statistiques qui sont pas
sérieuses et qui sont discutables non il
y a s'il y a un index il doit y avoir un
système de sanction et on aurait dû
commencer par là améliorer la place et
le travail des seniors c'est un vrai
enjeu quand vous perdez votre emploi
entre 50 et 60 ans le risque de ne pas
en retrouver un et quand même énorme une
réforme était était
utile selon vous elle était nécessaire
par exemple sur ce sujet oui et ce qui
aurait été utile c'est d'utiliser la
possibilité d'avoir une augmentation ou
pas des cotisations patronales en
fonction d'un index qui vérifie si oui
ou non il y a une volonté d'intégrer des
seniors dans le travail ça c'est une
vraie question elle n'a pas été posée
elle est posée alors peut-être que dans
le débat en tout cas moi j'indique qu'à
ce moment-là c'est index il doit y avoir
une contrepartie c'est sur les
cotisations retraite patronales si vous
respectez pas le l'objectif pour
permettre au Seigneur de travailler et
donc de cotiser et donc d'avoir un
équilibre plus solide du système de
retraite à ce moment-là il y a matière à
avoir des sentiments de départ quel est
votre position parce que Obs pardon mais
c'est pas très clair c'est 62 ans ou
c'est retour à 60 ans Alors c'est
effectivement plus clair du tout alors
je vous raconte une petite histoire
quand est-ce qu'a été décidé
là l'approche sur la durée de cotisation
par rapport à l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite plus personne s'en souvient
2004 Congrès de Dijon un vote aux
conquête Dijon on est en pleine réforme
des retraites raffarinfillon je sais pas
si vous en souvenez on voit Bernard
Thibault venir à Dijon et être applaudis
en ce moment particulier où la CFDT de
Chirec a eu fait un choix extrêmement
difficile et contesté il y a Dijon il a
été acté par François Hollande contre la
vie de Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'Henry
Emmanuelli et de Arnaud Montebourg et
Benoît Hamon à l'époque
qui voulait revenir à 60 ans et 37,5 à
nuitée qui était le sujet de faire le
choix de la durée de cotisation c'est ce
qui a fait la réforme Touraine lorsqu'on
est arrivé au gouvernement c'est une
décision qui remonte à loin aujourd'hui
le PS ne sait plus où il en est puisque
il est quelquefois pour le retour à 60
ans et 40 à 8t la dernière fois que
Olivier force s'exprimé c'est 60 ans et
43 à nuités c'est-à-dire la réforme
Touraine vaut mieux assumer la réforme
Touraine voilà c'est ce que je fais la
position du peps
la position du PS ça a toujours été
celle-là mais donc pour vous il faudrait
rester en état de la réforme Touraine et
avoir un travail et un vrai travail sur
le travail des seniors
de suivre la nuque qui demande un
certain temps si tu te décision qu'il a
prise dans le cadre d'un accord mais qui
n'a été discuté nulle part et je
rappelle que c'est à Dijon avec la
partie socialiste qui à l'époque faisait
plus de 100 000 militaires
retour à 60 ans
80 milliards
par an
je vous laisse faire le calcul bon donc
du coup pour revenir à la question de
Julien le 19 janvier vous serez dans la
rue ou pas
[Musique]
qui sont unanimes sur le sujet mais
c'est pas ce qu'il faut faire attention
c'est pas simplement est-ce que vous
êtes dans la rue on a l'impression qu'en
France enfin je veux dire vous voyez
comment le débat bascule oui parce que
la gauche et la France insoumise mettre
la rue comme un élément les syndicats
aussi mais les syndicats aussi d'accord
mais politiquement mettre comme un
élément
du des outils de gouvernement la rue
regardons quel autre possibilité
monsieur le folle parce que en
l'occurrence dans dans l'assemblée on
sait très bien ça risque d'être plus
compliqué de s'opposer au projet du
gouvernement encore plus avec un projet
de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale rectificative d'ailleurs je
voulais simplement vous
bien sûr que la protestation dans la rue
la manifestation et un élément de la
démocratie mais commencez comme question
sur un sujet comme la retraite lorsqu'il
y a un ancien ministre en lui disant
est-ce que vous allez être dans la rue
j'ai été ministre et j'ai rencontré des
gens dans la rue j'ai connu des
difficultés j'ai eu affronter des
mouvements et des colères je suis
parfaitement conscient j'ai même eu des
agriculteurs qui sont du cachet chez moi
dimanche soir ils étaient aussi dans la
rue et vous avez donc il faut avoir
cette comment dirais-je cette ce sens de
l'État pour dire oui la manifestation
oui la protestation ça fait partie de la
démocratie mais la responsabilité
politique ne s'exerce pas uniquement
avec la rue sinon responsabilité
politique pour vous c'est de proposer à
un projet alternatif
et financé et comment il est financé
c'est à dire que il faut enfin qu'on
arrive à
à construire des alternatives
qui soient acceptée et comprise par les
français pour devenir des alternances
politiques le problème aujourd'hui des
alternatives c'est très facile vous
dites sur la retraite je suis pas
d'accord et je reviens à 60 ans et à 40
annuités ça coûte 80 milliards on verra
ça plus tard il y a les dividendes comme
tout à l'heure bon il y a de l'argent il
y a très bien c'est facile une
alternative est très facile à construire
construire une alternative pour qu'elle
puisse devenir une alternance politique
ça c'est un autre sujet faut convaincre
50% des français donc là il faut se
creuser un peu plus la tête un dernier
mot là-dessus puisque vous avez été mise
avait été aussi par paroles du
gouvernement hier
l'actuel par parole du gouvernement a
dit ne pas se projeter dans l'idée d'une
mobilisation massive est-ce qu'un
porte-parole peut dire ça je vois ce
qu'il a tort et qui prend des risques on
sait pas ce qui peut se passer on sait
que il y a une crise que il y a des
difficultés que dans ces conditions là
une mobilisation massive et beaucoup
plus difficile que quand les choses sur
un sujet qui crispent si vous voulez de
d'exprimer une colère mais de dire
d'emblée quand on gouverne bah je le
crois pas je ferai très attention à ce
genre de pronostic on sait jamais ce qui
peut se passer voilà on va parler du
Parti socialiste oui il y a une journée
un peu décisive aujourd'hui puisque il y
a le vote dans le Nord
c'est aujourd'hui que que les 41000
adhérents à jour de cotisation du PS
votent pour l'une des trois notions
alors celle de Olivier Faure actuelle
patron du PS mais c'est que vous vous
soutenez aussi des laines Geoffroy et
celle du maire de Rouen Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol quel est votre pronostic
je vais éviter de faire des pronostics
moi j'espère que aujourd'hui la prise de
conscience qui est en train de monter au
sein du PS quand même avec en
particulier
cette nouvelle motion ou Théo la textes
d'orientation de Mayer Rossignol elle a
un Geoffroy ayant été de point de vue et
dans le débat
celle qui a été la plus claire et la
plus convaincante je le dis quand même
parce que c'est la vérité après le fait
que Nicolas Mayer Rossignol avait
refondation conteste aussi la ligne qui
est aujourd'hui celle d'Olivier Faure et
qui conduit à ce que sur la question des
retraites plus personne ne sait
exactement quelle est la position du
Parti socialiste de la même manière je
crois que c'était chez vous sur la
question du nucléaire bah on sait pas
trop s'il faut le garder s'il faut en
sortir donc on appelle un référendum et
c'est des franchis les Français qui
trancheront on est dans un moment où
politiquement on affirme plus aucune
ligne ni aucune position donc il est
temps de se poser quand même les bonnes
questions la politique c'est d'abord une
affirmation de choix de proposition de
projet et pas simplement une question
tactique et électorale voilà du coup
c'est pas une erreur d'avoir fait deux
listes face à Olivier forest est-ce que
c'est toujours cette dispersion ne va
pas favoriser sa réélection vous ne
souhaitez pas Nicolas May a reçu
surtout à la place d'Hélène Geoffroy
Geoffroy on va la mettre voilà elle
était opposante à Olivier Faure et à
cette ligne depuis le congrès de
Villeurbanne moi je l'avais été depuis
le Congrès d'Aubervilliers Nicolas Mayer
aussi a soutenu Olivier fort au dernier
congrès il était sur la ligne de Adidas
Go il y a un changement tant mieux parce
que je pense que c'est ça le fond de la
question mais il ne voulait pas
rejoindre parce que c'est à eux il faut
aussi poser la question rejoindre ce qui
a été fait jusqu'ici par Hélène Geoffroy
bon il y a deux motions est-ce que ces
deux motions feront plus de 50%. c'est
la grosse enjeux en fait je peux pas
vous dire à une coalition dès lors si
imaginons que que Olivier Faure n'arrive
pas à 50% ce sera la ce sera la solution
ce sera effectivement d'assumer une une
rassemblement pour prendre en charge la
responsabilité de gouverner ce parti
socialiste pour changer les choses faire
en sorte toujours la perspective
d'alliance à gauche ça me paraît évident
mais pas sur une ligne politique et
dictée par la France insoumise
aujourd'hui c'est ça la question c'est
la seule question que doivent se poser
les militants socialistes l'alliance à
gauche et nécessaire mais sur quelle
base politique je le rappelle et je l'ai
dit trouver des alternatives
alternatives et s'opposer c'est ce qui
est de plus facile construire un projet
qui soit aussi en capacité d'être une
alternance politique ça c'est beaucoup
plus difficile vous avez toute confiance
dans le déroulement du scrutin de ce
soir
à mon avis des décontestations il y en a
déjà que j'ai vu sur certaines boucles
là il y a déjà des contestations je
pense que tout ça bon va on verra bien
ce soir comment n'est pas garanti
de manière globale de est sincère après
si c'est serré voilà je me souviens de
quelques congrès quand c'est serré ce
qui ce qui est un peu original parce que
voilà là ça peut être compliqué vous
craignez d'ailleurs à ce titre une
explosion du parti à la suite
aujourd'hui il est tellement
en rupture et en tout cas en
contradiction avec tout ce qui a été
fait avant que que d'abord il y a
beaucoup de socialisme qui sont partis
et qu'aujourd'hui on est effectivement
sur un risque de de fracture je prends
la question dire retraites
affirmer aujourd'hui d'abord commencer
en disant c'est 60 ans et 40 à nuité
puis après dire c'est 60 ans et 43 on
voit bien qu'il y a à la fois pour ne
pas gêner ce qui est l'anus et
l'Alliance on reste sur la ligne de la
France insoumise que Olivier fort avait
lui-même contesté pendant la
présidentielle que maintenant il semble
accepter tout en essayant de mettre des
nuances et des différences on sait plus
où on est alors j'ai vu que à
l'Assemblée nationale sur la loi climat
et sur les énergies renouvelables là
pour le coup les socialistes sont quand
même à distance en effet
un manque de cohérence idéologique de la
part d'Olivier Faure qui risque de
fissurer le peste
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas comment je
vous ai rappelé qu'à Dijon il y a plus
de 100 000 habitants
aujourd'hui s'il y a quasiment oui au
total
voilà ça là aussi on pourrait discuter
qu'est-ce qui va rester à la fin
15-20000 militants qui vont voter et
encore pour certains parce que il y a
des élus derrière il y a un appareil qui
voilà bon écoutez voilà c'est ça
j'aimerais vous vous citer Olivier fort
qui disait dans une interview à
Ouest-France qui résumait en fait les
lignes défendues par les candidats il y
a celle du renforcement et du
rassemblement qui entend défendre et
celle de mes concurrents dit-il qui
prônent le repli sur soi avec comme
conséquence notre isolement vous prenez
le repli ah non moi je le prends pas du
tout le repli contraire moi je prône
l'offensive le problème d'Olivier fort
c'est que dans sa première formulation
effectivement il prennent le
rassemblement et c'est sa ligne son
mantra c'est l'alliance pour l'alliance
qui est un vrai sujet je l'ai dit on
peut pas ne pas penser qu'on a besoin
d'alliance mais la question qui était
posée avant c'est que la ligne de
l'Alliance c'était le Parti socialiste
qu'il a défini c'est aujourd'hui il
tourner la page de du quinquennat de
François Hollande c'est ce que j'ai
souvent répété il a voulu tourner une
page avec d'autres Johanna Roland
Nathalie a Perry qui était pourtant
proche de valse tous ces gens là en sont
dit allez hop on tourne la page c'est
très bien et c'est légitime te dire il y
a eu un quinquennat qui a vu un
président de pas se représenter donc il
faut quand même qu'on en tire des
conclusions c'était la trahison
l'expéculation c'est que François
Hollande et quinquennat on trahi vous en
rappelez quand on fait ça faut être
capable ensuite d'écrire une page
politique et là et là il y en a pas eu
il y a pas eu un seul débat moi la
présidentielle ou Olivier Faure dit bah
on a fait 1,7 avec un Hidalgo fallait
bien que je passe un accord si on était
tout seul mais pourquoi on a fait 1,7 y
a-t-il eu une fois un débat sur un
projet pour la France est-ce qu'on a été
capable d'organiser une discussion même
pas puisque j'étais venu ici et Public
Sénat était la seule
chaîne de télévision qui m'avait invité
au moment où je demandais un débat face
à un Hidalgo où tout le monde était
parti derrière un Hidalgo sans même se
poser la question de savoir pourquoi
faire quel est le projet et que cette
campagne avait commencé par je vais
doubler le salaire des professeurs et
j'étais venu ici d'ailleurs dire on
commence pas une campagne par une mesure
catégorielle où est-ce qu'on a discuté
nulle part donc Olivier fort porte la
responsabilité des échecs électoraux et
justifie son alliance et l'effacement du
PS par ces échecs il peut pas être à la
fois le responsable des échecs et en
même temps en tirer les conséquences et
continuer à dire que c'est à cause des
échecs qu'il est obligé de passer par
l'anus c'est son échec
pardon est-ce qu'il faut quand même
tourner une page selon vous parce que là
Julien situé Olivier Faure il y a aussi
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol et évidemment
qui parle notamment sur François
Hollande et qui dit qu'un ancien
président une parole libre et utile pour
la France c'est bien mais le socialisme
a besoin de renouveau d'être incarné par
une nouvelle génération mais ça c'est
toujours été le cas il faut renouveler
et je me répète un peu mais si on a
encore trop présent François Hollande
mais si il est trop présent de toute
façon que ces jeunes se posent la
question de savoir pourquoi sur les
grandes questions géostratégiques quand
on a un parti socialiste qui sait plus
il faut rester dans l'OTAN ou qui
accepte l'idée de la désobéissance
européenne dans un contexte
géostratégique et politique tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui qui sait qu'on va
venir voir pour discuter des questions
géopolitiques et géo stratégiques on
appelle l'ancien président de la
République parce que c'est une nouvelle
génération ne s'est pas où elle habite
voilà et donc si quelqu'un qui a un peu
d'expérience comme moi peut avoir un
message avant de dire
il est trop présent posez-vous la
question de savoir pourquoi mais s'il
est trop présent c'est parce que d'abord
il a été président de la République et
deuxièmement sur plein de sujets
aujourd'hui le Parti socialiste il
n'exprime rien monsieur le folle ce
parti socialiste que vous décrivez que
comme comme moribond avec une direction
qui n'assure pas ses responsabilités de
reconstruction
pourtant il risque de se parti il risque
de rester aux mains de d'Olivier fort il
y a quand même une bonne probabilité
qu'est-ce que vous ferez si c'est si
c'est le cas
j'ai fait un livre au moment et j'ai
demandé un débat au moment de la
présidentielle et j'ai quelques idées et
donc il va falloir porter des yeux parce
que il y a pas de débat au Parti
socialiste
je sais pas ce qu'il veut faire il
paraît qu'il veut organiser des débats
Olivier font il y en a un en tout cas
qui sera très clair sur la question
européenne la ligne de l'anus et qui est
la ligne aussi qui a été réaffirmée
pendant ce congrès puisque c'est plus il
y a des obéissances mais la dérogation
au traité pour un mieux 10 ans
écologique et social bon à partir du
moment où un pays et un grand pays et
donc dissocialise considère que on peut
déroger pour un mieux 10 ans parce que
on considère que nous portons un lieu
disant par rapport à l'Europe c'est on
dérange au traités qui sont signés ou au
compromis qui est trouvé et qui est
toujours difficile à trouver c'est pas
la peine de demander aux autres après
d'appliquer les traiter donc il faut une
liste socialiste aux européennes
socialiste c'est clarifier la position
par rapport à l'Europe parce que là
c'est tout sauf
oui je le dis c'est une ligne qui
conduit à quoi à la crise européenne
quand et les filles ont des roches aux
règles quand elle est fit et la nupesse
d'ailleurs avec des écologistes qui me
disent rien sur ce sujet propose 250
milliards de dépenses publiques pour
soutenir la consommation dans le même
temps ou par exemple les écologistes
sont pour la décroissance passons
contradictions majeure mais 250
milliards de creuses Jean-Luc Mélenchon
dit l'Europe n'a doit nous soutenir
parce que nous sommes la France et que
de toute façon le risque de crise
est-elle si nous allons jusqu'au bout de
la logique que la nôtre personne ne
pourra nous empêcher de le faire parce
que sinon c'est la crise et c'est
l'effondrement dans un contexte comme
celui dans lequel on vit aujourd'hui
faire le pari de la crise européenne
provoquée par un gouvernement de gauche
en France c'est un pari que moi je ne
veux pas prendre je suis pas sûr d'avoir
saisi si Monsieur fort est réélu à la
tête du PS est-ce que vous restez au PS
ah moi je resterai au PS la nups
aujourd'hui il y a des doubles
appartenance j'ai pas de problème mais
je vais continuer à m'exprimer de
manière très claire et avec un objectif
pesé dans un débat pour la gauche à
l'échelle du tout le pays début décembre
vous appeliez à la aux Assises de la
gauche elle devait se dérouler début 203
on en est où vous allez les organiser
on va attendre que le Congrès se termine
il y a par exemple dans les motions qui
sont présentées ou les Théo par mayor
Rossignol et Geoffroy des Assises de la
gauche
c'est proposé pour le coup si il y a ce
changement on peut aller tous ensemble
dans un débat pour rebattre des cartes
repenser les propositions et le projet
une Bernard Cazeneuve moi je signais le
manifeste de Bernard Cazeneuve et
initiative bien entendu si on doit en
prendre une ensemble il faut qu'on la
prenne ensemble moi je reste persuadé
que c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire un
dernier mot peut-être très rapidement
oui alors pour François Olivier Giesbert
qui était invité dimanche de grands
rendez-vous Europe 1 Les Échos cnews
l'éditorialiste disait que vous faites
partie avec Bernard Cazeneuve le site
des gens exceptionnels il y a raison
donc Emmanuel Macron devrait s'entourer
alors déjà d'une est-ce que vous êtes
flatté mais est-ce que vous pourriez
faire partie d'un gouvernement
d'Emmanuel Macron donc moi je garde la
première partie de la phrase sur
exceptionnelle moi après Emmanuel Macron
j'ai pris mais ma décision il y a
longtemps moi j'étais ministre avec
Emmanuel Macron bon il a réussi
il est devenu président de la République
j'ai pas suivi par exemple d'autres ça
c'est pas mon histoire c'est pas ma
manière de voir les choses c'est pas
c'est pas aussi les convictions sur un
certain nombre de sujets en particulier
la fiscalité que je ne partage pas avec
Emmanuel Macron donc moi j'ai pris ma
décision il y a longtemps donc je vois
bien que François après quelque chose de
très sympathique que je prends avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'honneur non la
deuxième formule non moi j'ai je repense
et je pense profondément que c'est hyper
centre qui existe avec Emmanuel Macron
tiens avec Emmanuel Macron et que la fin
du mandat d'Emmanuel Macron et donc du
macronisme mais je l'ai écrit à
plusieurs repris c'est un risque pour
notre démocratie s'il y a pas des
alternatives capables d'être des
alternances politiques merci Stéphane
merci beaucoup d'avoir bonne année à
vous la Une de La Voix du Nord Julien
oui qui revient sur sur la catastrophe
de l'effondrement des deux immeubles à
Lille et du long travail d'enquête qui
est actuellement m'aider
merci Stéphane